you
this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
some Citroen Tannenbaum when in walks
someone who's usually a pretty
intimidating customer Solid Snake
usually not a lot of people really talk
to Solid Snake he seems to always want
to be alone
and it certainly tries to indicate that
it wants to be alone so they sits down
orders a drink up there I notice he's
carrying his box with him
and it's one thing to carry a box around
every once in a while that's already
straight by he carries it everywhere to
parties to get togethers just every way
you can imagine he always has them books
with him on everybody seen up with that
box and yet nobody ever questioned
Zimmer no dress like that I guess I
would be rushing to me the phone today I
was feeling pretty ballsy I decide I'm
gonna ask him about this so I approached
him and I'll say mr. snake on the side I
just collaborate the Knights hello
what's up with the box I think looks at
me it says nobody's ever asked that
before but they're just too intimidated
I said but I'll do the right thing Isis
you did the right thing I'll tell you
why I always carry it around
it's my security blanket well yeah I
wouldn't think about like you would have
a security my case this is boy box is a
proud piece of art you can do anything
with it you can hide in it you can build
a fort out of it even there I'll say it
you can pack things in it
it's my closest friend has helped me
through all sorts of troubles I've got
mr. slick you're grown man from men can
be seen carrying a box around all this
time on me doesn't it seem that the
childish don't you think you should move
on he says you should know that my
habits were done it in front of my own
eyes
so tell her to know that at all it's
only is only five years old a burglar
broke into his house his mom and dad
said hide under this box and don't come
out no matter what master chases mom
what happened they said I hinted that
box didn't come up or anything but I
could see the little slip you know we
put your hands in to carry the box I saw
everything
and yeah he shot down a short boat but
he wasn't just a traditional robber you
see he had weird mental issues he did
all sorts of strange things and I said
like one more than he do
well gonad came and start dancing on top
of their bodies I guess I had some soul
condition why they kill people you like
to tap dance on top of the corpses
nothing no Astor was my wife
it doesn't stop there
then put his hand in the back say stop
using that as a puppet show what the
Muppets actually you know that Peyton's
face routine they used to do all the
time yeah here we enacted that with my
parents bodies and just to make things
worse
he made my mother one of the male dates
and made my father Miss Piggy
my father is not as pinky I said honor I
know him
your father's not miss big enough said
look say yeah I can't imagine a
five-year-old boy watching this in front
of his eyes and he says it gets worse
after he did the puppet show with my
parents he took him up and he start
using them as nunchucks like he was a
ninja you know Bruce Lee I think he was
making all those weird sounds like oh he
slammed them into the face he slammed
him into the picture flames he slammed
him all over the place
I said mr. snake on so sometime though I
deal with more of this he says it gets
worse after he did the nunchuck bit he
opened up my parents took out all the
bows and start playing the xylophone
with her rib cages under the sea
actually from the Little Mermaid I don't
think that movie came out yet but he saw
one of the VHS previews and there the
song on there and yeah I guess he really
wanted to and I'll stare mr. snake for
the love of God tell me it doesn't get
any worse and he says it gets worse
after I played the xylophone with my
parents skeletons he took what was
remaining of their bodies food in a
blender pissed him to it and then
blended them together and drank their
remains he had a unique name for
actually I believe it was called
two dead parents pizza with my stinky
yellow urine
then took the change from a piggy bank
and pissed off
understanding that dumbfounded hearing
the storage of code believe what you're
saying and it looks me in the eye and
says so if it's alright with you is it
okay if I continue to carry my box
around without giving any questions
about it
I mean if it's alright with you and I'll
sit yeah that's alright mr. snake I'm
that's alright I thought that more
terrible that I did that day
mati bastard I remember Mario came up
after him and he pointed a snake and he
said boy top of the guy with the box and
I said don't ask and they said why not I
said because he just might tell you more
strange things as a bartender resumed
ostrich these are the pixel palace so
not see lot of strange things of a bar
to her and the pizza palace